Depuis quelque temps j'avais envie
de faire une vidéo sur le Bitcoin
et puis, il y a quelques semaines,
Gilles qui est créateur de la chaîne Heu?reka
en a faite une qui est vachement bien.
Et à la réflexion je me suis dit qu'il restait quand même
quelques détails techniques à expliquer,
notamment sur le concept de Blockchain
qui est la technologie qu'il y a derrière le Bitcoin.
Et du coup j'ai quand même décidé de faire une vidéo
et j'ai demandé à Gilles de venir m'aider un peu !
- Salut Gilles, Tu nous dis un mot sur ta chaîne ?
- Hello David et merci de m'avoir invité
à participer à cette vidéo.
- De nous avoir invités !
- Ah oui pardon, de nous avoir invités.
Donc Heu?reka c'est une chaîne de vulgarisation
qui s'intéresse principalement
à la finance et à l'économie.
On y aborde des sujets divers du genre :
Quel est le lien entre l'économie réelle et la finance ?
Quel est l'intérêt des différentes monnaies ? ou encore,
Qu'est-ce que c'est que le Quantitative Easing ?
- Bah pourquoi tu choisis les sujets les plus chiants,
on parle aussi du loup de Wall Street, de The big short,
on vous dit tout sur les traders
et on vous explique d'où vient l'argent.
Alors avant de regarder la suite,
allez vous abonner à Heu?reka.
On entend souvent que le Bitcoin
serait une monnaie électronique,
mais en fait vous savez, la monnaie actuelle,
elle est déjà largement électronique.
Quand vous payez des petites sommes, vous payez
peut-être avec des pièces ou avec des billets
mais dès que vous faites une transaction
avec une carte bleue ou un virement,
la banque débite votre compte
et elle crédite celui du vendeur.
Il n'y a pas d'échange d'argent physique,
tout se passe dans les comptes de la banque
donc une bonne partie de la monnaie
qu'on utilise est déjà électronique.
Aujourd'hui c'est à peu près quel pourcentage, Gilles ?
Aujourd'hui la masse monétaire totale en zone Euro
c'est 11 000 milliards d'euros
et pourtant il n'y a qu'un peu plus de
1 000 milliards d'euros en pièces et en billets
donc l'argent que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
est à plus de 90% électronique.
Toute cette monnaie elle n'existe
que dans les livres de comptes de la banque.
Evidemment aujourd'hui, ce n'est pas un vrai livre, c'est
plutôt une base de données de toutes les transactions,
c'est-à-dire un gros fichier informatique.
Mais du coup, si quelqu'un pirate
le fichier informatique ou bien l'efface ?
Le Bitcoin c'est aussi une monnaie électronique
mais elle est décentralisée, c'est ça le mot important.
C'est-à-dire que la base de données
de toutes les transactions,
elle n'est pas gérée par une instance centrale
comme une banque,
mais elle est partagée
dans un immense réseau peer to peer.
C'est-à-dire que tous les gens
connectés au réseau Bitcoin
peuvent héberger une copie de la base de données
qui contient toutes les transactions.
Une base de données qui est distribuée comme ça, déjà,
on peut penser qu'elle est plus difficile à détruire
puisqu'il existe plein de copies partout.
Et puis on n'a plus besoin d'une autorité centrale
comme une banque,
c'est-à-dire que n'importe qui peut inscrire
une transaction dans la base de données.
Par exemple, imaginons que
je veuille acheter sa lampe à Gilles.
Heu, celle-là? J'ai dû l'acheter pour environ
100€ donc ça doit faire 0, ...
Pop, pop, pop, tu fais des vidéos sur les traders
et tu ne sais même pas négocier ?
David, on peut te vendre la lampe pour 10 Bitcoins.
Ok, 10 bitcoins.
Bon, pour payer la lampe,
j'inscris dans la base de données partagée, le message:
"Moi, David, donne 10 Bitcoins à Gilles".
La transaction est enregistrée et les nœuds du réseau
communiquent pour se passer l'info
et ensuite Gilles peut m'envoyer sa lampe.
Bon évidemment, il y a un problème avec ce système.
Aujourd'hui une banque,
elle sert quand même à quelque chose
et notamment elle authentifie
les auteurs des transactions.
Avec ce que je viens de vous décrire
on a l'impression que n'importe qui
peut inscrire des transactions en mon nom.
- Quoi ? C'est trop cher 10 Bitcoins?
T'inquiète on va s'arranger.
Moi, David, donne 10 Bitcoins à Gilles... et voilà.
Et puis, autre chose à laquelle
la banque sert aujourd'hui,
tout simplement à vérifier que j'ai l'argent pour payer.
Et puis accessoirement, elle empêche
que n'importe qui viennent modifier
ou pirater la base de données des transactions.
Pour résoudre tous ces problèmes
le Bitcoin se base sur deux technologies:
la signature électronique et la blockchain.
Commençons par le premier problème.
Quand on voit un message dans la base de données
qui annonce un transfert de Bitcoin,
comment on peut être certain de son auteur?
Et bien on va utiliser le principe de la
cryptographie asymétrique.
J'en avais un petit peu parlé dans mon
épisode sur les codes secrets.
En cryptographie généralement on utilise une clé
qui permet de chiffrer et déchiffrer des messages.
Dans les techniques de chiffrage des plus simples,
on ne peut déchiffrer un message
que si on possède la clé qui a servi à le chiffrer.
Mais il existe des systèmes de chiffrage plus sophistiqués comme ce qu'on appelle l'algorithme RSA
qui sont asymétriques, c'est-à-dire
la clé qui sert à chiffrer le message
n'est pas la même que celle qui sert à déchiffrer.
Par exemple, si on ne possède que la clé
de chiffrement, on peut chiffrer des messages
mais pas les déchiffrer,
il faut une autre clé pour ça.
Alors je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir bien compris :
Comment est-ce qu'on peut réussir à déchiffrer
un message mais ne pas être capable de le chiffrer.
Il suffit de faire la même opération
en sens inverse, non?
Non, parce qu'en fait que le chiffrage asymétrique
ce n'est pas une opération lettre à lettre,
elle transforme le message dans son ensemble.
Elle est un peu lourde, compliquée mathématiquement
et impossible à faire dans l'autre sens
si on n'a pas la clé de déchiffrage.
C'est un peu comme si tu avais un dictionnaire
français-hongrois mais pas la partie hongrois-français.
Du coup tu peux facilement traduire
un mot du français vers le hongrois
mais ce n'est pas facile de connaître le
sens en français d'un mot hongrois.
Une des utilisations classique de la
cryptographie asymétrique
c'est d'avoir une clé de chiffrement qui est publique,
c'est-à-dire que vous la donnez à tout le monde
et n'importe qui peut vous envoyer
des messages codés.
Mais la clé de déchiffrement, elle reste privée,
vous la gardez uniquement pour vous.
Vous êtes le seul à pouvoir lire les messages
et ceux qui les écrivent ne peuvent pas se lire entre eux.
En fait ils ne peuvent même pas se relire.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'utiliserait pas
un chiffrage classique avec une seule clé
mais en donnant une clé différente
à chaque personne
Le résultat serait le même, non ?
Du coup je ne vois pas vraiment l'intérêt
de ton truc asymétrique compliqué.
L'intérêt c'est que par exemple, un journaliste
ou une agence de renseignement
peut avoir une clé publique qui permet à n'importe qui
de leur envoyer des messages codés
et il n'y a pas eu besoin d'avoir
un échange en clair avant.
Donc ça permet de recevoir des infos
tout en protégeant la source.
Enfin, c'est surtout très utilisé
dans les communications sur internet.
Bon, ça c'était le principe de la cryptographie
asymétrique pour recevoir des messages.
Maintenant le principe de la signature électronique
en fait, c'est exactement l'inverse de ça.
Imaginez que j'ai une clé de chiffrement
que je garde pour moi, qui soit privée
et que la clé de déchiffrement soit publique.
Si j'inscris un message comme :
moi David donne 10 Bitcoins à Gilles
et que je chiffre avec ma clé privée,
ça donne du charabia.
J'inscrit ce charabia sur la base de données.
Ensuite n'importe qui peut appliquer ma clé publique
et déchiffrer le charabia pour reconstituer
le texte de la transaction.
Mais du coup, on est bien certain
que c'est moi qui ai inscrit la transaction
puisque personne d'autre n'aurait pu
la chiffrer de cette manière-là
et donc c'est ça qui fournit l'authentification.
Les transactions sont donc impossibles
à falsifier sans posséder la clé privée
mais elle sont aussi impossibles à répudier.
C'est-à-dire qu'une fois vous avez payé,
vous ne pouvez pas nier l'avoir fait.
Donc en pratique pour échanger des Bitcoin,
il faut créer un compte et vous recevez un identifiant,
une clé privée que vous gardez pour vous,
évidemment
et une clé publique qui sera connue
de tous les nœuds du réseau.
Et la clé privée vous permet
d'authentifier vos transactions.
Par contre, si vous la perdez
cette clé privée, c'est mort.
D'ailleurs anecdote amusante à ce sujet,
en 2009, alors que le Bitcoin ne valait presque rien
et qu'il était facile d'en récupérer,
James Howells, citoyen britannique,
en a obtenu la modique somme de 7500.
Quelques mois plus tard, après s'être désintéressé
de cette monnaie électronique alors inconnue,
James a tout simplement,
lors d'un petit ménage de printemps,
jeté à la poubelle le disque contenant
la fameuse clé privée qui donnait accès au Bitcoin.
Une erreur qui fait très très mal, puisque 7500 Bitcoins
aujourd'hui ça vaut entre 2 et 3 millions d'euros.
Un détail très important sur la structure
des transactions, quand on inscrit une transaction,
on inclut aussi une référence
vers les transactions précédentes
qui nous ont fourni l'argent qu'on choisit de dépenser.
Je vais prendre un exemple. Au lieu d'écrire simplement : Moi David donne 10 Bitcoins à Gilles,
j'écris : Moi David donne 10 Bitcoins à Gilles,
en utilisant les 10 Bitcoins
que j'ai reçus avant-hier de Nota Bene.
Oui, parce qu'avant-hier avec Nota Bene, on a fait
une partie de bras de fer et c'est moi qui ai gagné.
Ah, c'est comme ça que tu dis gagné toi alors.
Tu veux peut être que l'on remette ça, non ?
Non mais, on avait déjà remis ça.
J'avais quand même gagné.
On va peut-être pas abuser Monsieur !
Bon bref, tu m'as filé 10 bitcoins
et moi j'inscris dans la base de
données que ce sont ces mêmes 10 bitcoins
que je vais utiliser pour
acheter sa lampe, à Gilles.
Quand on fait des références comme ça,
aux transactions passées, ça a deux intérêts.
Le premier c'est que, pour valider une
transaction,
on n'a pas besoin de connaître la position exacte
du solde du compte de quelqu'un.
Il suffit juste de vérifier que les transactions auquelles
il fait référence comme étant la source des bitcoins
n'ont pas déjà été utilisées
dans une transaction passée.
Et le deuxième intérêt c'est que, ça empêche
de faire du copier-coller de transaction.
Donc t'es en train de me dire que depuis tout à l'heure
que j'essaie de copier-coller la transaction des
10 Bitcoins pour en récupérer 20 et que ça marche pas,
en fait c'est normal?
C'est pas un bug de mon téléphone?
Et bien non, parce qu'on verrait
que ça fait deux tentatives d'utilisation
de ces 10 Bitcoins que j'ai reçu de Nota Bene.
Finalement, le Bitcoin se comporte
un peu plus comme du cash électronique,
c'est-à-dire de l'argent liquide électronique
parce que, comme avec des pièces ou des billets,
il y a cette idée que la double dépense
est impossible, on ne peut pas dépenser
deux fois les mêmes Bitcoins
qu'on a reçus de quelqu'un.
Et si Nota Bene t'avait filé 20 Bitcoins alors que toi tu ne veux m'en donner que 10 pour la lampe?
Et bien, il existe un système de remboursement
qui permet d'utiliser ces 20 Bitcoins
pour te donner 10 Bitcoins à toi
et puis pour me redonner à moi-même
les 10 Bitcoins restants.
Donc à priori là, on a un bon système,
il est ouvert, il est partagé,
et puis il y a une technique d'authentification
qui empêche de faire n'importe quoi.
Il y a juste un petit problème.
Il y a plein de copies de la base de données
et elles doivent communiquer entre elles
et comment elles font pour se synchroniser.
Ça peut poser des soucis, notamment s'il y a des conflits
quand quelqu'un essaye de faire une double dépense.
Imaginons que je proclame donner
10 Bitcoins à Gilles d'un côté du réseau
en utilisant les 10 Bitcoins
reçus de Nota Bene.
Puis exactement au même moment,
dans une autre copie de la base de données
à un autre endroit du réseau,
je déclare utiliser ces même 10 Bitcoins
pour acheter autre chose à quelqu'un d'autre.
Comment les copies de la base
de données se synchronisent?
Et laquelle des deux transactions va vraiment compter ?
L'idée c'est que, chaque nœud du réseau enregistre
les nouvelles transactions dont il a connaissance
dans une liste de transactions "en attente".
Et puis évidemment, il partage l'information.
Et donc tous les nœuds du réseau possèdent
une liste de transactions en attente qui peuvent être
très légèrement différentes les unes des autres
et chaque nœud fait, comme ça,
croître sa liste de transactions en attente.
Puis périodiquement, environ toutes
les 10 minutes,
il y a un des nœuds du réseau dont on prend
les transactions en attente et on les déclare "validées"
et tout le monde se synchronise dessus.
Ce groupe de transactions on l'appelle "un bloc".
Et on remet ça toutes les 10 minutes.
Et du coup, la liste des transactions qui sont validées
elle se présente sous la forme d'une suite de blocs,
un toutes les 10 minutes et c'est pour ça
qu'on appelle ça la chaîne de blocs ou, blockchain.
Mais alors comment est-ce qu'on choisit le nœud
qui détient les transactions validées ?
C'est toujours le même ou alors non,
on en choisit un au hasard?
La règle c'est que, pour proposer
sa propre liste de transactions en attente
comme étant le nouveau bloc sur lequel
tout le monde doit s'aligner,
il faut d'abord lui trouver un nom, un identifiant
et on s'est mis des règles qui font que
trouver un identifiant à un bloc,
c'est un problème mathématique
extrêmement compliqué.
Donc chaque nœud du réseau travaille en permanence pour essayer de résoudre ce problème mathématique
et trouver un identifiant pour
sa liste de transactions en attente
et le premier qui y arrive peut proposer son bloc
et tout le monde se synchronise dessus.
Ah ça ça me dit quelque chose, c'est le coup
du problème de math hyper difficile à résoudre.
Sauf que moi, j'aimerais bien comprendre
pourquoi c'est difficile à résoudre.
Eh bien, on va voir ça!
On a vu que ce qui permettait à la chaîne de blocs
de se construire de manière régulière,
c'est que pour proposer un nouveau bloc,
il fallait résoudre d'abord un
problème mathématique compliqué,
ce problème sert à trouver
un nom au bloc, un identifiant.
Pourtant, trouver un identifiant
ça n'a pas l'air très compliqué comme problème.
Alors pour vous expliquer ça, il faut d'abord
que je vous explique ce que c'est que le hachage.
Une fonction de hachage, c'est une
fonction qui prend en entrée,
une chaîne de caractères de n'importe quelle longueur
et qui donne en sortie, une autre chaîne de caractères
qui est de longueur fixe.
Par exemple ici, on a 16 caractères
et ce qu'on veut c'est que le moindre changement
dans la chaîne d'entrée,
provoque un grand changement
dans la chaîne de sortie.
Par exemple là, si je change un A en O
ou que j'ajoute un point d'exclamation
à la fin de la phrase,
la chaîne de sortie est complètement modifiée.
Une des applications du hachage c'est de vérifier
qu'un téléchargement s'est bien passé.
Si vous téléchargez un gros fichier,
il y a toujours un risque qu'une petite partie
du fichier soit mal transmise
et que ça suffise à rendre
l'ensemble du fichier inutilisable.
Une solution c'est que, celui qui met
le fichier en téléchargement
le fait d'abord passer dans une fonction de hachage
pour en sortir une chaîne de caractères
qui est en quelque sorte
l'empreinte digitale du fichier.
Si le fichier que vous avez reçu diffère ne serait-ce que d'un bit du fichier d'origine,
le résultat de son hachage
sera complètement différent
et vous pourrez vous rendre compte qu'il y a un souci.
C'est le principe de ce qu'on appelle
la somme de contrôle, ou checksum.
Pour trouver un identifiant
à chaque nouveau bloc de la blockchain,
on va aussi utiliser le principe du hachage.
Pour ça on fabrique un fichier qui contient
toutes les transactions qu'on veut valider,
ainsi que l'identifiant du bloc précédent
et on fait passer le tout par une fonction de hachage.
On obtient ainsi une suite de caractères
qu'on va utiliser comme identifiant.
Et ce qui fait que la chaîne est une
chaîne c'est que l'identifiant d'un bloc
est utilisé pour calculer l'identifiant du bloc suivant.
L'intérêt de ce système, c'est de protéger
la base de données contre la moindre modification.
Si vous voulez changer une transaction
ou même juste rajouter un 0,
ça va complètement changer le hachage
et donc ça va changer l'identifiant du bloc.
Mais comme l'identifiant du bloc est utilisé
dans le hachage du bloc suivant,
il faut aussi changer l'identifiant du bloc suivant
et ainsi de suite dans toute la chaîne.
Donc impossible d'aller changer
une transaction dans le passé
sans avoir à recalculer tous les identifiants
de tous les blocs qui sont arrivés depuis.
et je vous rappelle, des blocs il y en a un toutes les 10 minutes.
Bon il n'y a pas à dire, à mon avis, ils ont pensé à tout,
ça a l'air béton comme protection cette blockchain.
Et bien, je n'en suis pas si sûr,
d'après ce qui vient d'être expliqué,
trouver un identifiant ne repose que sur le hachage
or une fonction de hachage ce n'est pas si lourd que ça.
Il y a même des tas de site internet qui peuvent le faire.
Donc un éventuel pirate pourrait tout à fait rajouter
ses blocs à toute vitesse dans la blockchain.
Non, alors ce qui protège de ça,
c'est le fait qu'on a ajouté
des conditions supplémentaires sur l'identifiant
qui fait que le trouver, c'est compliqué.
L'idée c'est que, quand on fabrique
le fichier qu'on veut hacher,
on prend donc l'identifiant du bloc précédent,
la liste des transactions,
mais on ajoute aussi à la fin,
un nombre qu'on appelle un Nonce
et la présence de ce nonce va évidemment
modifier le résultat du hachage.
En fait, on impose des conditions sur le résultat
qui font qu'il faut essayer plein de nonces différents
avant d'en trouver un qui colle
et le seul moyen d'y arriver, c'est la manière bourrine.
On essaye plein de nonces à toute vitesse
jusqu'à en trouver un qui colle,
comme si on essayait de trouver un digicode
d'immeuble en tapant plein de codes au hasard
et les conditions sont faites pour
qu'une solution soit trouvée
en moyenne toutes les 10 minutes dans le réseau.
Evidemment au fur et à mesure que le réseau grandit
et que la puissance de calcul des ordinateurs augmente,
on rend les conditions de plus en plus difficiles
pour rester sur cette moyenne de 10 minutes.
Donc si on résume, chaque nœud du réseau a sa liste
de transactions en attente et il travaille comme un bourrin
pour faire en sorte que cette liste de transactions
en attente devienne le prochain bloc.
Donc chacun essaie de trouver
un identifiant à sa liste de transactions,
le premier qui y arrive, il est l'élu
et tout le monde s'aligne sur lui et prend sa liste
de transactions comme étant le nouveau bloc
et on recommence.
Ce qui est intéressant avec ce système
c'est qu'on protège la blockchain de la fraude
en demandant de manière un peu
artificielle aux nœuds du réseau
de résoudre un problème compliqué
pour avoir le droit de contribuer,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la preuve de travail.
Bah oui, pour contribuer il faut bosser.
La conséquence de ça, c'est que la capacité à frauder
devient liée à la puissance de calcul dont on dispose
et pas au nombre de nœuds du réseau qu'on possède,
parce que créer plein d'adresses IP pour avoir
plein de nœuds du réseau c'est facile,
par contre aligner un paquet de processeurs
pour aller plus vite que tous les autres,
c'est une autre affaire.
Bon là, on est presque au bout de la technologie
de la blockchain, il reste juste un problème à résoudre.
Il existe une petite probabilité que
deux nœuds du réseau
arrivent à proposer tous les deux leur bloc de
manière quasiment simultanée
et puis il existe aussi un tout petit risque
que quelqu'un arrive, sur un des noeuds du réseau,
à pirater un bloc ou deux, s'il est
suffisamment puissant et avec un peu de chance.
Heu, je ne suis pas sûr de comprendre là.
Imagine que David accepte de nous payer
10 Bitcoins pour la lampe.
On attend une dizaine de minutes
puis la transaction apparaît dans un bloc,
a priori ça veut dire que cette transaction
a bien été validée.
Donc on envoie la lampe à David.
Sauf qu'à ce moment-là il existe
quand même encore une chance
que la transaction soit piratée voire supprimée.
Quoi ? Comment ?
Eh oui, et en cas de piratage du
dernier bloc ou bien si, pas de chance,
deux noeuds du réseau arrivent tous les deux à
proposer leur bloc et bien il se passe un truc simple,
on se retrouve avec deux chaînes de blocs différentes.
Et là, la règle est simple,
tous les nœuds du réseau
doivent conserver les deux chaînes
mais par contre on ne travaille
que sur la plus longue des deux,
ce qui fait que, très rapidement, l'une des deux chaînes
va prendre le pas sur l'autre.
Donc avant de m'envoyer ta lampe, le mieux c'est
quand même d'attendre environ une 1 heure - 5/6 blocs
pour être sûr que la transaction qui va te payer
fait partie d'un bloc qui va bien
être dans la chaîne qu'on va conserver.
On voit donc que dans le principe du fonctionnement
de la blockchain, donc qui sécurise le Bitcoin,
on est protégé par le fait que chacun ne possède
qu'une faible puissance de calcul comparée au total.
En fait, si quelqu'un voulait vraiment
compromettre la blockchain,
il faudrait qu'il possède plus de 50%
de la puissance de calcul de tout le réseau.
Mais du coup, on peut se demander
pourquoi est-ce que tous les ordinateurs du réseau
accepteraient de mettre leur puissance de calcul
au service de la protection du Bitcoin.
Et bien, il y a une réponse simple pour ça,
c'est qu'on les paye, et on les paye en Bitcoin.
Il faut savoir que quand un bloc est validé,
c'est-à-dire qu'un nœud du réseau arrive à résoudre
le problème mathématique compliqué,
il reçoit pour sa peine 25 Bitcoins.
Et au cours actuel du Bitcoin,
ça fait pas loin de 10 000€.
Et ces Bitcoins, ils viennent de nulle part,
ils sont créés artificiellement pour l'occasion,
c'est d'ailleurs le seul mécanisme de
création de nouveaux Bitcoins.
Et c'est pour ça que les ordinateurs
qui participent à la sécurisation du réseau,
on les appelle parfois des mineurs,
en référence aux mineurs
qui allaient chercher de l'or
pour augmenter la masse monétaire.
Alors 10 000 € pour résoudre un problème
mathématique, ça à l'air vachement intéressant.
sauf que, maintenant, il faut mettre tellement
de puissance de calcul pour y arriver le premier,
qu'il n'y a quasiment aucune chance
d'y arriver tout seul, il faut se grouper.
et puis le mécanisme est tel, que la récompense
en Bitcoin va décroître au cours du temps.
Donc au final, la masse monétaire
des Bitcoins, on sait qu'elle va converger
vers 21 millions de Bitcoins. Pas plus.
On a ici tous les avantages du système Bitcoin.
On a un système qui est centralisé
sans autorité de régulation
avec un mécanisme de création monétaire
qui est connu d'avance et transparent
et des frais de transactions qui sont réduits.
C'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui, on entend surtout parler
du Bitcoin pour des transactions illicites
ou bien pour des logiciels malveillants
qui vous cryptent votre ordinateur
et vous demandent des rançons en échange.
enfin quand même, avant de vous lancer
dans le grand banditisme avec le Bitcoin
gardez en tête que l'anonymat n'est que théorique.
C'est vrai que votre nom n'apparaît pas
explicitement dans les transactions
et si vous êtes le seul à avoir votre clé privée,
en principe vous êtes le seul à savoir
que c'est vous qui avez fait la transaction.
sauf qu'il a déjà été montré
sur des exemples qu'on pouvait
assez facilement désanonymiser des données
en se basant sur des motifs récurrents.
Et n'oubliez pas, tout ce qui est
inscrit dans la blockchain
est quelque chose qui est éternel,
impossible à modifier.
Donc pensez-y avant d'aller acheter de la drogue.
D'ailleurs au-delà du Bitcoin, on peut penser
à tout un tas d'autres applications pour la blockchain,
notamment dans des situations où on souhaite
afficher des informations publiquement
mais de manière infalsifiable.
Comme par exemple pour faire
du vote en ligne ou bien du notariat.
Aujourd'hui il est évidemment difficile de prédire l'avenir
du Bitcoin ou bien les applications de la blockchain
mais ce qui est sûr, c'est qu'à mon avis,
on risque d'en entendre encore beaucoup parler
dans les prochaines années.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Merci à Gilles qui m'a aidé
et n'hésitez pas à aller voir sa vidéo qui donne pas mal
de détails dont je n'ai pas parlé dans cette vidéo.
Merci beaucoup à Nota Bene
qui m'a laissé gagner au bras de fer.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'oubliez pas
de la partager notamment sur les réseaux sociaux.
Vous pouvez suivre les actus de la chaîne sur Facebook,
Tweeter. Vous pouvez me souvenir sur Tipeee.
Vous pouvez aller lire le billet qui accompagne cette
vidéo sur mon blog Science Étonnante pour plus
d'informations un peu plus techniques
et vous pouvez aussi aller jeter un œil
à mon livre que j'ai sorti chez Flammarion.
Merci à bientôt!